sexy space aliens multi-eyed monsters
that will rip your head off
and jackie robinson taking on ctulu
hbo's lovecraft country
executive produced by jordan peele and
jj abrams
promises to take us on a wild ride of
sci-fi and horror
and think-story is here to break down
all the episodes analyze those hidden
easter eggs and discuss
some insane theories for episodes to
come like who is this mysterious red hat
woman who did atticus call in korea and
how the hell are t-bone stakes only 81
cents a word of warning before we begin
if you're worried about spoiling the
2016 book of which the show is based on
don't worry i haven't read it i also do
not have advanced copies of the show so
all the theories and discussions are
based solely on the info we're given so
with that out of the way
if you want to see more videos like this
make sure to like and subscribe
it really helps the channel so let's get
into it welcome to the korean war
notice how all the soldiers our main
character atticus freeman fights here
are
asian a clue to where he was deployed
during his time in the military you may
also have noticed how the image on
screen
transitions from black and white to
color from reality to
fantasy this makes sense because it's
all a dream ending with famous
african-american baseball player jackie
robinson beating the [ __ ] out of an h.p
lovecraft monster known as ctulu
i hope i'm saying that right jackie is a
fitting foe since the background
voiceover about a story of a young
american boy in his dream
is from the 1950 film the jackie
robinson story
now there are some other cool things
here like what appear to be
female roman centurions fighting in the
background and this red-skinned alien an
allusion to the princess of mars book
that we later see atticus reading a
princess of mars is the story of an
ex-soldier who is transported to a new
world kinda like atticus here who has
returned home and must navigate this new
world of lovecraftian [ __ ] there's a
great discussion between atticus and a
woman who were left stranded when the
bus broke down on whether or not you can
like art if it was written by a racist
hp was a well-documented white
supremacist yet
atticus likes his book john carter was
an ex-confederate soldier in the
princess of mars book yet
atticus likes reading stories with him
in it as atticus explains
stories are like people love them
doesn't make him perfect you just
try and cherish them overlook their
flaws
i also want to note that i'm pretty sure
the red alien here is the woman atticus
calls in korea
the actress is jaime chung who plays
jiha who we haven't met yet
and it would make sense since the start
of the dream sequence he's fighting in
korea they embrace hinting that there
may be a love connection between the two
atticus wakes up from his dream he's on
his way back home to chicago after
receiving a cryptic letter from his
father who has gone missing so he meets
up with his uncle george on a quest for
answers his father's letter exclaims
that atticus has a secret birthright
that's been
kept from him that his mother's
ancestors hailed from a place called
arkham massachusetts the same name as
the publishing firm that printed
lovecraft's collection of short stories
the outsider and the others arkham is
also home of herbert west the reanimator
a scientist who can reanimate the dead
using a special solution he created
something tells me he'll be making an
appearance in future episodes
george tells atticus that he's got it
all wrong that it's not
arkham he's looking for it's artem with
a d
and there just so happens to be a
mention of artem in the fictional
massachusetts county of
devon but before atticus sets off he
visits sammy the bar owner one of the
last known
people to see his father before he
disappeared sammy's located at denmark
vesey's bar
denmark vesey the name of a slave who
was executed for allegedly planning a
revolt
it's fitting that atticus's father's
last known whereabouts was a bar
since it's hinted at that his father is
an alcoholic which could explain
atticus's tumultuous relationship with
him
these marks on the wall here were from
atticus being slammed into it by his
abusive father
later in the episode atticus calls out
his uncle for not doing anything
to help him when he was younger
ironically this happens when letty is
being abused by her brother
atticus is about to go in and help when
george says this
it's family business
[Music]
atticus learns that his father left the
bar with a rich white dude in a silver
sedan
we'll get to that sedan in a bit as it
makes several appearances throughout the
episode i also want to acknowledge this
short scene of atticus walking past the
army recruitment office
two important things to note one how the
army recruits young african americans
looking for a way out of poverty just
like atticus was recruited and two how
this links into atticus's relationship
with his father their big falling out
had to do with him
signing up atticus's father didn't like
the idea of his son
fighting for a country that doesn't care
about black people
at his father's place atticus finds a
copy of the count of monte cristo right
next to a bottle of booze of course the
story is about a man who is wrongfully
imprisoned escapes jail and sets about
exacting revenge on those responsible
for his imprisonment i think it's a
little too early to infer why his father
was reading this book just yet but the
book gets its own close up next to a
family photo so we'll keep this in the
back of our minds as the episodes
continue
anarchist also picks up his father's gun
and makes a cryptic phone call to a
woman
in korea he likely met her while
deployed there and the fact she says he
shouldn't have left could mean
two things a they had some romantic past
or b
she knows something bad will happen to
him or hey it could be a bit of both and
guess what's parked outside the house
here
that silver sedan the next day atticus
george and letty embark on their journey
to artem
george runs a guidebook called the safe
negro travel guide a nod to the green
book even his daughter's comic has an ad
for it colored in green on the back the
name of her comic arithia blue comes
from greek mythology
arithia was a queen of the amazons and
george's wife hippolyta
is also the name of an amazonian queen d
george's daughter has drawn
several monsters on her father's map
including this one of the grim reaper
atop a clock foreshadowing how atticus
george and letty literally have to beat
the clock in order to survive their
encounter
with the racist sheriff but we'll get
into that in a bit as a three travel
self there's a great montage of how it
was like
living as an african american in the
south in the 1950s
racist billboards an american way sign
featuring a white family overlooking a
lineup of
african americans waiting at the bus
stop and even this separate entrance at
a theater this image is an actual
recreation of the 1956 gordon parks
photo
colored entrance in mobile alabama which
was shot for life magazine the voiceover
during this segment is taken from a
legendary debate between
james baldwin and conservative william f
buckley in which baldwin argued that the
american dream came at the expense of
blacks the team stops her lunch at a
local diner which used to belong to a
black woman named lydia however it's
undergone new management by a group of
racist firefighters atticus george and
letty are actually run out of town and
in one of the most
wtf moments of the episode are saved by
the silver sedan the pursuer's car is
completely flipped in the air as if
hitting some invisible wall
and the woman who appears from the
silver sedan is platinum blonde
blue eyes and dawn's red gloves and a
hat but i'll delve more into her when we
get to the end of the episode
at marvin's things get a little
complicated when they learn the history
of artem remember that artem's last
known mention was in a county that's
presently known as
devon county well the county seat of
devon the town that is the governmental
center of a county
is called bideford bideford happens to
be the name of a town in england that
had one of the last witch trials
a woman was hung for fornicating with
the devil who appear to her as a black
man
and marvin tells them this new bideford
was founded by witch hunters for the
past several years people have gone
missing in the woods and he believes it
could be the result of a racist
sheriff named eustis hunt artem was
settled the same time as bideford and
according to marvin should be located
somewhere in this patch of forest
so in order to find artem they'll need
to traverse devon county
which is a sundown county a sundown
county is one in which all white
municipalities or neighborhoods practice
a form of segregation by excluding
non-whites via a combination of
discriminatory local laws
intimidation and violence and that's
exactly what happens when they're pulled
over by sheriff eustis they're given a
few minutes to get out of the county
before sundown or else they'll be
arrested and even when they do make it
out on time the sheriff's men stomp them
down the road
taking them to the forest to be killed
it's here that lovecraft country really
digs deep into horror as the group is
attacked by lovecraftian creatures known
as shoghos
these many-eyed dracula-like creatures
are afraid of light a weakness atticus
george and letty later used to their
advantage
seeking refuge in a nearby cabin they
learned that if they can
survive until sunup they could make
their escape but they'll need more light
to last
luckily there are flares in the car and
the headlights will help as well
so letty decides to make a run for it
since she was a track star in high
school
unfortunately for atticus and george
sheriff eustis succumbs to his wound and
morphs into one of those creatures
and it looks like they're done for until
letty smashes through the cabin scaring
the creature away
but what's really interesting here is
when they're surrounded
the sound of a whistle makes the
shoghoth's back off now in shogoth lore
shoghoffs were controlled through
hypnotic suggestion i'm curious if they
are somehow controlled by the
blonde-haired woman or
man we see at the end notice how this
man has a red pocket square just like
the woman wore red the red to me
suggests the devil and we've already had
one allusion to the devil when marvin
told them that the
last witch trial in bideford was done
because a woman had sex with the devil
in the form of a black man i can't help
think that there's some sort of
connection there
we also see a silver sedan parked
outside the giant mansion george atticus
and letty make it to at the end of the
episode
this is artem the man here says welcome
home and my mind is spinning with
questions
is atticus's father here likely yes but
what is his connection to these artem
residents
we get a clue early on that atticus's
mother came from ancestors
at artem atticus's father found out
where his wife's family came from
and that atticus has a sacred secret
legacy that's been kept from him so the
fact this man says welcome home means
that this place is tied to his family
secret i know it sounds crazy but could
he be related to these white guys
perhaps not by blood but by some other
way artem is also said to be the
location of miskatonic university
which sponsored the fossil hunting
expedition to the mountains of madness
at the mountains of manus is another
novel by lovecraft in the fact we see
these
digging shogoths who seemingly can be
controlled and in lore built the cities
of their masters
i can't help but think there's a
connection and this won't be the last
time we see them
so that's it for this first episode of
lovecraft country but i want to hear
your thoughts and theories about the
episode below
remember to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much